I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Right, everybody. We are still saying goodbye to Toby. It is goodbye, Toby. Part two. It's a long goodbye, but he deserves it. He's been at the company a long time. He deserves a two-parter. Michael's going to give him a big send-off, lady. He sure is. Guys, it's season four, episode 19, written by Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein, directed by Paul Feig.
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。好了，各位。我们仍在向托比告别。这是《再见，托比》下集。这是一场漫长的告别，但他当之无愧。他在公司呆了很长时间。他值得拥有上下两集。迈克尔要给他办一场盛大的欢送会，女士。他当然会。伙计们，这是第四季第19集，由詹·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·菲格执导。
Here is a summary of part two of Goodbye Toby. Okay. An extravagant goodbye party is being thrown in the parking lot for Toby. Ryan is arrested for fraud. Michael discovers big news about Jan. Jim plans to propose to Pam, but gets upstaged by Andy. And Phyllis discovers a secret. Does she ever? All right. Jumping right in, fast fact number one. I'm calling this party time. Are you going to give me a breakdown of all the party? You know I am. We got fan questions from Abby M and Yvette M. How many days did it take to film Toby's Goodbye Party? How long did it take to set it up? Well, you know I went to Kentipedia. He said it took one full day to set it up, and two days and nights to film. We filmed
以下是《再见，托比》下集的剧情摘要。好的。停车场正在为托比举办一场奢华的欢送派对。瑞安因欺诈被捕。迈克尔发现了关于简的重大消息。吉姆计划向帕姆求婚，却被安迪抢了风头。菲利斯发现了一个秘密。她什么时候没发现过？好了。马上切入正题，趣味事实一。我把这叫作派对时间。你要给我讲讲整个派对的细节吗？你知道我会的。我们收到了来自艾比·M和伊薇特·M的粉丝提问。拍摄托比的欢送派对花了几几天？搭建它花了多长时间？嗯，你知道我去查了“肯特百科”。他说搭建花了一整天，拍摄用了两天两夜。我们拍摄于
April 17th and 18th of 2008. The Ferris Wheel came from a company called Awesome Events, and it cost us $7,500 to rent that Ferris Wheel for three days. Dang. That's a pricey Ferris Wheel. Here's what I remember about those party scenes, Angela. It was very hot during the day, and then at night it got cold. Yeah. I remember I had hand warmers in my pockets at night and you know when you go skiing and you put those toe warmers in your ski boots? I had those in my shoes for the night shoot. Also, whenever they didn't see our feet, we had Uggs on, and Jenna, I have an Ugg catch later in this episode. Whose Uggs do you see? Not gonna tell. Guys, you're gonna have to wait for it. She's making you wait for it.
2008年4月17日和18日。摩天轮来自一家名为“精彩活动”的公司，租用这个摩天轮三天花了我7500美元。天哪。那真是一个昂贵的摩天轮。关于那些派对场景，我记得的是，安吉拉，白天非常热，然后到了晚上就变冷了。是的。我记得我晚上口袋里装着暖手宝，你知道当你去滑雪时，你会把那些鞋垫暖宝放进滑雪靴里吗？我夜间拍摄时就在鞋子里放了那些。还有，每当他们拍不到我们的脚时，我们都穿着Ugg雪地靴，珍娜，这集后面我有个“Ugg抓帮”环节。你看到谁的穿Ugg了？不告诉你。伙计们，你们得拭目以待了。她让你等着瞧呢。
Also in between takes, do you remember our wardrobe department had these big puffy coats? Like the kind that go down to your ankles, giant puffy coats, and they would bring them out to us so that we could put them on in between takes outside when we were cold. And you know what? What? I still have mine. You do? Oh, what a score. Yeah. And on the label on the inside of the coat, it says Pam written in Sharpie. Aw. Cause that's how they knew whose coat belonged to who. They Sharpied it. Well, these were like giant sleeping bags. Yes. Made into jackets. Well described. Okay. Fast fact number two. I'm kind of sad. I know. This is not just goodbye, Topi. Nope. This is goodbye, Kentopedia. Yes. Kent Sabornak.
还有在拍摄间隙，你还记得我们的服装部门有这种巨大的蓬松外套吗？就像那种一直垂到脚踝的巨大蓬松外套，他们会把它们拿给我们，这样我们在外面觉得冷时，就可以在拍摄间隙穿上。你知道吗？什么？我到现在还留着我的呢。你有？哦，真是赚大了。是的。而且在衣服内侧的标签上，用记号笔写着“帕姆”。啊。因为那是他们用来辨认谁的外套是谁的标志。他们用记号笔写的。嗯，这些就像巨大的睡包。是的。做成了夹克。形容得真贴切。好吧。趣味事实二。我有点难过。我知道。这不仅仅是再见，托比。不。这是再见，肯特百科。是的。肯特·萨博纳克。
This was the end of his run on the office. Yeah. After this, he moved on and he became the producer and production manager for anger management, dear white people, and most recently the Connors. He is an amazing, amazing production manager, you guys. We were so lucky to have him for four seasons and office ladies has been so lucky that he saved like everything. Talk about digital hoarder. Kentopedia is giving you a run for your money, Angela. Well, I think he's beat me, but I just love him and we loved him so much. Jenna, in anticipation of this being his last episode, I went through and found all of these emails during this week that I traded with Kent. This was like towards the end of my pregnancy and he and
这是他在《办公室》任职的尾声。是的。在此之后，他继续前行，成为了《愤怒管理》、《亲爱的白人》以及最近的《康纳一家》的制片人和制片经理。伙计们，他是一位了不起、了不起的制片经理。我们非常幸运能拥有他四季的时光，而《办公室女士》也非常幸运，他几乎保留了一切。说到数字仓鼠症，“肯特百科”可让你破费不少啊，安吉拉。嗯，我觉得他把我比下去了，但我就是爱他，我们太爱他了。珍娜，为了庆祝这是他的最后一集，我翻看了这周我和肯特往来的所有这些电子邮件。这大概是在我怀孕晚期的时候，他和
I were having to schedule a lot of things around my OBGYN appointments and everything. And if I could share anything with you guys is the kindness and the thoughtfulness that this man had for every member of the cast and making the show the best it could be. And we were so sad to see him go. I just love this guy. I love him too. And I love being in touch with him. And he was so great to us on the office and he's been so great to us on office ladies. We love you, Kentopedia. We love you, Kentopedia. And I'm going to share a few of our emails later in this episode. Angela, I want to share one of my favorite fun facts about Kent as we say goodbye to him. Okay, what? In his youth, Kent was an
我不得不围绕我的妇产科预约等事情安排很多行程。如果我可以跟你们分享什么，那就是这个男人对剧组的每一位成员所倾注的善良和体贴，他致力于让这部剧达到最佳状态。看到他离开，我们非常难过。我就是喜欢这家伙。我也很喜欢他。而且我很喜欢跟他保持联系。他在《办公室》对我们太好了，在《办公室女士》上也对我们太好了。我们爱你，肯特百科。我们爱你，肯特百科。在这集的后面，我会分享一些我们的电子邮件。安吉拉，在我们向肯特道别之际，我想分享一个我最喜欢的关于他的趣事。好的，什么？在年轻时，肯特曾是
assistant to the creator of Golden Girls. Her name is Susan Harris. And she loved Kent's last name so much that when she wrote Golden Girls, she named B. Arthur's character Dorothy Zabornak. Amazing. Yes, he was the inspiration behind that name. He told me he was beyond excited by this honor. He was like, I mean, who wouldn't be? And then he went on to be the first assistant director on Golden Girls. And he said B. Arthur was like a second mother to him. He just loved her. That is so wonderful. I love all of that. We love you, Kent. Okay, rounding out my fast facts, fast fact number three. Angela, you came up with this idea and I just loved it. I think we should do it for every character. And now I'm like,
《黄金女郎》创作者的助理。她的名字叫苏珊·哈里斯。她太喜欢肯特的姓氏了，以至于在写《黄金女郎》时，她将贝·阿瑟饰演的角色命名为多萝西·萨博纳克。太棒了。是的，他就是这个名字背后的灵感来源。他告诉我，他为这份荣誉感到无比兴奋。他说，我的意思是，谁不会呢？后来他继续担任了《黄金女郎》的第一助理导演。他说贝·阿瑟对她来说就像第二个母亲。他简直太爱她了。那真是太棒了。我喜欢所有这些。我们爱你，肯特。好了，收尾我的趣味事实，趣味事实三。安吉拉，这个主意是你想出来的，我太喜欢了。我觉得我们应该为每个角色都这样做。现在我觉得，
oh, we might have missed a few. We might have to, in a revisited, do this for other characters. That's right. Here's what we're talking about. Angela said, whenever we say goodbye to a character, we should give them a show Bible goodbye. So I went through the show Bible and I gathered facts about Toby Flandersen. Yay. Here they are. Toby Flandersen, graduate of Bishop O'Hara High School, class of 89. He is divorced, but his wife is still his emergency contact. Although her last name is Becker now. Hmm. During his 12 years working HR at Dunder Mifflin, he has explained female anatomy to Dwight, told Kevin he should ditch Dunder Mifflin's health care plan and get on his fiancee Stacy's plan instead because
哦，我们可能漏掉了一些。我们可能不得不在重温节目中为其他角色也这样做。没错。这就是我们要说的。安吉拉说，每当我们要和一个角色道别时，我们都应该给他们一个“剧本圣经告别”。所以我翻阅了剧本圣经，收集了关于托比·弗兰德森的事实。耶。它们在这里。托比·弗兰德森，奥哈拉主教高中89届毕业生。他离异了，但他的妻子仍然是他的紧急联系人。尽管她现在的姓氏是贝克。嗯。在他为邓德·米夫林工作人力资源的12年里，他向德怀特解释过女性解剖结构，告诉凯文他应该抛弃邓德·米夫林的医疗计划，转而加入他的未婚妻斯黛西的计划，因为
it's definitely going to be better. He sent out a memo regarding Jim and Pam's PDA and he attended Jan's deposition and was present for the reading of Michael's diary. Toby is one of the founding members of the finer things club. He bought Angela her baby jazz poster and he can run a mile in seven minutes. He's been trying to flirt with Pam and ask her out ever since season three. That is also how long he's been talking about going to Costa Rica. He started talking about that ever since he heard the Scranton branch might be closing and now after a very awkward moment of rubbing Pam's knee, he is finally leaving. Although guys, he is going to come back. Spoiler alert. Oh, I love that. I love the show Bible
那绝对会更好。他发出了一份关于吉姆和帕姆公开秀恩爱的备忘录，他出席了简的作证听证会，并在场宣读了迈克尔的日记。托比是精致生活俱乐部创始成员之一。他给安吉拉买过婴儿爵士海报，他跑步一英里只需七分钟。自从第三季以来，他一直试图调情帕姆并约她出去。这也是他谈论去哥斯达黎加的时间长度。自从他听说斯克兰顿分公司可能要关门以来，他就在谈论这个，现在，在经历了一个非常尴尬的抚摸帕姆膝盖的时刻后，他终于要离开了。不过伙计们，他会回来的。剧透警告。哦，我喜欢那个。我喜欢剧本圣经
goodbye. Show Bible goodbye. It's like a show Bible eulogy. Mm hmm. Little bit. Well, we'll definitely have to do that for a few characters in a revisited like for Karen Philippelli. Oh, yeah. That's going to be in a revisited. We'll do it. That is all I have Angela. Quick fast facts today. I like it. I have some fun stuff from the shooting draft. But maybe before we get into this episode, we should take a little break. Let's take a little break. But I've got a lot to say about this one. So we might be short here up on top, but we're going to be long later. That's what she said. Is that a thing she said? Maybe. Maybe. I don't know. You decide over the break. Okay. All right, we are back. And Michael is so
告别。剧本圣经告别。这就像是一篇剧本圣经悼词。嗯哼. 有一点。好吧，在重温节目中，我们绝对得为某些角色这么做，比如卡伦·菲利佩利。哦，耶。那会在重温节目里出现。我们会做的。这就是我的全部了，安吉拉。今天的趣味事实真简短。我喜欢。我有一些来自拍摄初稿的有趣内容。不过也许在我们进入这一集之前，我们应该休息一下。让我们休息一下吧。但我对这一集有很多话要说。所以我们前面可能会短一些，但后面会很长。她就是这么说的。那是她说过的话吗？也许吧。也许。我不知道。你们在休息期间决定吧。好吧。好的，我们回来了。迈克尔感到非常
excited to have his moment. It is time for Toby's exit interview. Michael shows up with a gift. It's wrapped. There's a ribbon. Yeah, he walks in the conference room with Toby. He shuts the door. He's ready to get started. But then what happens? He says this, can I just say that of all the idiots and all the idiot villages in all the idiot worlds, you stand alone, my friend. And then right as he's about to really go off, Holly enters and he's like, Oh, hey. And she's like, Yeah, I've got to be here. This part of my job. And he's like, No, no, no, shouldn't you just tour some more? Go see the Baylor. She goes, maybe later. This is actually part of my job. And then Pam walks in. She's like, Do you
兴奋，终于迎来了他的高光时刻。是时候进行托比的离职面谈了。迈克尔拿着一份礼物出现。它被包装好了。上面有缎带。是的，他拿着托比走进了会议室。他关上门。他准备开始了。但接下来发生了什么？他说了这样的话，我能说吗，在所有白痴村庄里所有的白痴中，在所有白痴世界里，只有你独树一帜，我的朋友。然后就在他准备彻底发飙时，霍莉进来了，他说，哦，嘿。然后她说，是的，我必须在这里。这是我工作的一部分。然后他说，不，不，不，你不应该再去参观一下吗？去看看贝勒。她说，也许晚点吧。这其实是我工作的一部分。然后帕姆走进来。她说，你
need me to take notes? Toby's all over it. Toby's like, Stay, Pam, stay. She's like, All right. Well, this is now not going as Michael had planned. He gets out his note cards. He's written some questions. Again, Steve Carell should have won 15 Emmys. I mean, come on. Yeah, this is his having all this stuff he wanted to just tee off on Toby about and now having to dial it back and somehow be acceptable in front of this woman he's falling in love with every moment Steve crushes. His first question is, who do you think you are? And Toby goes, I'm Toby. Now, I hope you noticed in the background, I'm going to substitute my own horn. I am taking notes. No, I know. I watched you write it all down.
需要我做记录吗？托比全盘接受。托比说，留下来，帕姆，留下来。她说，好吧。好吧，这下事情的发展完全不按迈克尔的计划走了。他拿出了他的便签卡。他写了一些问题。再说一次，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔本该赢得15座艾美奖的。我的意思是，拜托。是的，这是他把所有想对托比倾泻的不满都准备好了，现在却不得不收敛，并设法在这个让他每分每秒都深陷爱河的女人面前表现得可以接受，史蒂夫的演技简直绝了。他的第一个问题是，你以为你是谁？托比说，我是托比。现在，我希望你们注意到背景里，我要插一句。我在做笔记。不，我知道。我看着你把它们全写下来了。
And I am actually writing down who are you? And then I wrote down Toby. And a couple times I wrote down he is Toby. But my whole backstory and Angela, I loved doing these scenes. I loved every time Pam's sole purpose in a scene was to take notes because I was just an audience member. I got to just sit there. I didn't have any like real lines I had to say or anything I had to do. You just had to try not to laugh. Pretty much. But I always took diligent notes. I really did because I liked to pretend that Michael would ask me to transcribe these meetings later. I like to think he made you go in his office and read the whole thing back to him. Just so he could feel important. This was like something he saw in an old movie once
而我实际上在写“你是谁？”然后我写了“托比”。好几次我写下了“他是托比”。但我整个背景故事，安吉拉，我太喜欢拍这些戏了。我喜欢帕姆在某个场景中唯一的目的就是做笔记的时候，因为我只是个观众。我只要坐在那里就行了。我没有必须说的真正台词，也没有必须做的任何事。你只需要努力不笑出声。差不多吧。但我总是勤奋地做笔记。我真的这么做了，因为我喜欢假装迈克尔后来会要求我把这些会议记录誊写出来。我喜欢想成他让你去他的办公室把整件事读给他听。只是为了让他觉得自己很重要。这就像他在一部老电影里看到过的，
that secretaries do for their bosses. That's right. His second note card says, what gives you the right? And this is when Holly steps in. She's like, you know what? I brought the binder. Do you want to use it? Take a look at it? Yeah. And Michael starts to ask Toby if he has any suggestions on ways that, you know, Dunder Mifflin could improve itself. And Toby seems like he's going to answer this question until, oh my God, Steve puts his hands up to his face to shield himself from Holly and he gives Toby this look. It's so good. He actually mouths the words, I'll kill you. Is that what he's saying? I missed it. He says, I'll kill you. And in the script, it's written that he does the slit the throat,
秘书为老板做的事。没错。他的第二张便签卡写着，谁给你的权力？这就是霍莉介入的时候。她说，你知道吗？我带了活页夹。你想用它吗？看一看？嗯。然后迈克尔开始问托比，他是否有任何关于邓德·米夫林可以如何自我改进的建议。托比看起来正要回答这个问题，直到，天哪，史蒂夫把双手举到脸前挡住霍莉，并给了托比这样一个眼神。太棒了。他甚至做出了口型“我要杀了你”。那是他说的吗？我没看见。他说，“我要杀了你”。剧本里写着他做了割喉的动作，
you know, the finger across the throat gesture. Yeah. But I don't know if this was Steve improvising. I feel like he probably gave them a few different choices. But the one they picked was him whispering, I'll kill you. It's so amazing. And Toby just goes, I guess everything's okay. Yeah. And he's like, you know, he has this moment where he's like, I mean, I made it this far. Why not? Well, Pam is going to suggest that Toby open his gift. Toby open it. What is it? And Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, you know what? You guys, it's a rock with a note on it that says suck on this. I watched this episode with Lee. He laughed so hard at this joke. He couldn't stop laughing that it was a rock. He just thought that was so funny. Michael, you know,
你知道的，手指划过喉咙的手势。是的。但我不知道这是否是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。我觉得他可能给出了几种不同的选择。但他们选中的是喃喃地说“我要杀了你”。太惊艳了。托比只是说，我想一切都还好吧。是的。然后他说，你知道，他有那么一刻觉得，我的意思是，我都走到这一步了。为什么不呢？好吧，帕姆建议托比打开他的礼物。托比打开它。是什么？迈克尔却说，不，不，不，不，不，不，你知道吗？伙计们，这是一块附有纸条的石头，上面写着“吸这个”。我和李一起看了这一集。他被这个笑话逗得哈哈大笑。他笑得停不下来，居然是一块石头。他只是觉得这太搞笑了。迈克尔，你知道的，
acts like he had no idea. And he's like, who pulled this prank on Toby? This is horrible. And Dwight's like, you told me to do it. And he's like, shh. And then he goes, you know what this was? It was a psych, psych, psyched you out. Because there's a real gift coming. And this is my second favorite thing to do as Pam, after taking notes in a meeting, which is painting Michael into a corner. And she says, what's the gift, Michael? What is it? Oh, is it your watch? And he's like, it is. It is my watch. How did you know? And she says, I just knew. He's so ticked off. He has to give Toby his watch. You know what? That's a genuine Seiko piece. He's going to have to give Toby the certificate that's framed as well, I guess. I guess he will. This delightful scene
表现得好像他完全不知情，他说，是谁对托比开这个玩笑？这太可怕了。德怀特说，是你让我这么做的。然后他说，嘘。然后他说，你知道这是什么吗？这是一次“诈唬，诈唬，骗了你”。因为真正的礼物还在后头。这是我作为帕姆在开会记笔记之后第二喜欢做的事，那就是把迈克尔逼入绝境。她说，礼物是什么，迈克尔？到底是什么？哦，是你的手表吗？他说，是的。是我的手表。你怎么知道的？她说，我就是知道。他气坏了。他不得不把自己的手表送给托比。你知道吗？那是一块货真价实的精工表。我想他还得把装裱好的证书也送给托比吧。我想他会的。这个有趣的场景
is interrupted by some hubbub in the bullpen. Everyone is gathered around Jim's computer watching a YouTube video. Yeah, Ryan is being arrested. And someone has uploaded the moment. And they're all watching it. I want you guys to know that they actually put that video on YouTube. It was a private account. So John is actually watching it during that scene. We all are. But it was a private account. When the episode aired, they made the video go live on YouTube so everyone could watch it. Oh, that's so great. I didn't know that. Yeah. But Michael is very upset. He's in his office and Holly is saying to Toby, what do you do in this situation? Toby says, I don't do anything. Just leave it alone. But Holly is amazing. She goes into Michael's office
被办公区的一阵喧闹打断了。大家都围在吉姆的电脑周围看YouTube视频。是的。瑞安被捕了。有人把那一刻上传了。他们都在看。我想让你们知道，他们真的把那个视频发到YouTube上了。那是一个私人账号。所以约翰在那场戏里其实真的在看它。我们都在看。但那是私人账号。当这一集播出时，他们让这个视频在YouTube上公开了，这样每个人都可以看。哦，太棒了。我不知道。是的。但迈克尔非常沮丧。他在办公室里，霍莉对托比说，遇到这种情况你该怎么办？托比说，我什么也不做。别管它就行了。但霍莉太棒了。她走进迈克尔的办公室，
and she really comforts him. Michael is crying. He's really sweet. He says, I'm worried about my friend. Yeah. And she says, that's normal. You take the time you need to have your feelings. Which leads to just a wonderful talking head, Angela, that I love where Michael says, Holly is sweet and simple like a lady baker. And he just wouldn't be surprised to find out that she'd worked in a bakery before coming to Dunder Mifflin. I mean, he's pretty sure she's baked on a professional level. Because baking is love, right? Yeah. Only sweet ladies bake. Sweet ladies who take care of you. Yeah. Aw. Well, after this very sweet Michael talking head, we are all going to go out in the parking lot because the party is starting. Oh, yeah. But before we get into that parking lot,
真正地安慰了他。迈克尔在哭。他真的很贴心。他说，我担心我的朋友。是的。她说，这很正常。你花点时间去感受你的情绪吧。这就引出了一段非常精彩的访谈，安吉拉，我太喜欢了，迈克尔在其中说道，霍莉甜美而单纯，就像一个女面包师。他甚至不会惊讶于发现她在来邓德·米夫林之前曾在面包店工作过。我的意思是，他挺确信她有过专业水平的烘焙经历。因为烘焙就是爱，对吧？是的。只有甜美的女士才会烘焙。照顾你的甜美女士。是的。啊。好吧，在这段非常甜蜜的迈克尔访谈之后，我们都要走到停车场去，因为派对开始了。哦，耶。但在我们进入那个停车场之前，
Jenna, I need to share a little backstory. Okay. Have you ever been on the phone with someone and you actually hear that person go into a full flop sweat? Where is this going? Because I have. Okay. I have. And that person was Kent Zabornak. Oh my gosh. Oh gosh. Not only did I remember this, but then I found some emails between Kent and I that really painted the picture. And I wanted to share the story with you guys that I almost didn't make it to the parking lot. Oh, now I know what you're talking about. In my emails, I found that on Thursday, April 10th of 2008, at 4 p.m., I had a routine checkup with my OBGYN. I emailed Kent about it. He said, no problem, Ange. We'll have you wrapped in time to make it to that doctor's appointment.
珍娜，我需要分享一点背景故事。好吧。你有没有跟某人通过电话，然后你真的听到那个人大汗淋漓？这扯到哪儿去了？因为我有。好吧。我有。那个人就是肯特·萨博纳克。我的天哪。哦天哪。我不仅记得这个，我还找到了我和肯特之间的一些电子邮件，它们真实地还原了当时的情景。我想和大家分享这个故事，我差点没能走到停车场。哦，现在我知道你在说什幺了。在我的邮件里，我发现2008年4月10日星期四下午4点，我跟妇产科医生有个例行产检。我为此给肯特发了邮件。他说，没问题，安吉。我们会让你及时赶完并去赴那个医生预约的。
So, lady, while I was at my doctor's appointment, you know, how they sort of check all your vitals and do everything. And I had had, like, I was feeling like a little bit of cramping, but nothing I was really worried about. And she was like, Angela, you're having contractions. And I said, what? And she said, yeah. And she immediately sent me to the hospital. From your doctor's appointment? From my doctor's appointment at four o'clock. Now I'm in the hospital. I'm having contractions every five minutes. And around six o'clock in the evening, Ginny O'Keefe, who is our second AD, called me to tell me my call time, right? For the next day. For the next day. She's like, hi, Angela. Your call time tomorrow is 5.30 a.m.
所以，女士，当我在医生的预约时，你知道，他们会检查你所有的生命体征并做所有事情。我当时觉得，好像有点宫缩，不过没什么让我真正担心的。然后她说，安吉拉，你在宫缩。我说，什么？她说，是的。她立刻把我送去了医院。从你的医生预约那里？从我四点钟的医生预约那儿。现在我在医院了。我每隔五分钟就宫缩一次。大约在晚上六点左右，我们的第二副导演吉尼·基夫打电话告诉我我的通告时间，对吧？第二天。第二天。她说，嗨，安吉拉。你明天的通告时间是早上5点30分。
And I said, Ginny, I'm in the hospital. She said, what? I said, I'm having contractions. And she goes, okay, okay. I will get back to you. Literally three seconds later, my phone rings and it's Kent Sabornag. And I will never forget the first thing he said to me. He said, hey, hey, Ange, we having this baby today? But like his voice cracked and went up. He's like, we having this baby today? Because what you guys have to know is they were building a frickin' Ferris wheel in the parking lot. That's right. And to give you guys some context, this was all happening about three weeks before your due date, right? Yeah. We just had a few more days of filming with you. Everyone just assumed
我说，吉尼，我在医院呢。她说，什么？我说，我在宫缩。她说，好的，好的。我待会儿联系你。 literalmente三秒钟后，我的电话响了，是肯特·萨博纳克。我永远不会忘记他对我说第一句话。他说，嘿，嘿，安吉，我们今天要生这个孩子吗？但他的声音都劈了，音调拔高了。他说，我们今天要生这个孩子吗？因为你们必须知道的是，他们正在停车场搭建一个该死的摩天轮。没错。为了给你们一些背景信息，这一切发生在你预产期前大约三周，对吧？是的。我们只有几天就要拍完你的戏份了。每个人都以为
that we would finish this episode and then you would go off on your summer hiatus and have your baby. Kent thought he had time. But in reality, you are in the hospital and he was probably standing in the parking lot as they're assembling this Ferris wheel and he's freaking out. Yeah. How does Andy propose if Angela can't be there? Yeah. In front of the Ferris wheel. So I said, Kent, I don't know. I don't know if I'm having this baby tonight. And he said, well, would you keep me posted? I said, sure. And it turned out to be false labor. I was there till about two in the morning. I did have to go work a half day the next day. And let me tell you, Kent had already hired a stuntwoman. Her name was Melissa Barker.
我们会拍完这一集，然后你就会开始你的暑假并生下你的孩子。肯特以为他还有时间。但现实中，你人在医院，而他可能正站在停车场看着他们组装这个摩天轮，他急坏了。是的。如果安吉拉不在，安迪怎么求婚？是的。在摩天轮前面。所以我说，肯特，我不知道。我不知道今晚能不能生下这个孩子。他说，好吧，你能随时向我汇报吗？我说，当然。结果证明那是假性宫缩。我在那里待到了大约凌晨两点。第二天我确实还得去上半天班。而且我告诉你们，肯特已经雇好了一个特技替身。她的名字叫梅丽莎·巴克。
And she was to be my body double for the rest of this shoot. They really wanted to try to make sure I did not have to work if I was not in a speaking scene, right? They would use Melissa. Angela, it was so weird to have her on set because she was dressed just like you. She had her hair done just like you. From behind, she seriously looked like you. So yes, if there was a scene in the conference room and you were just not speaking, she would be sitting there. And I would forget that she wasn't you. Well, listen, this all happened on a Thursday night. By Saturday, Kent sent the whole cast this email, Saturday, April 12th. Hey, you guys, our one liner schedule will be coming out later tomorrow. Please be advised that we are trying
她将担任我这次拍摄剩余部分的替身。他们真的很想确保我如果不在有台词的场景中就不用工作，对吧？他们会用梅丽莎。安吉拉，片场有她真是太诡异了，因为她穿得跟你一模一样。她的发型做得跟你一模一样。从背后看，她真的看起来就像你。所以是的，如果会议室里有一场戏而你只是不说话，她就会坐在那里。而我会忘记她其实不是你。好吧，听着，这一切都发生在周四晚上。到了周六，肯特给整个剧组发了这封邮件，4月12日星期六。嘿，伙计们，我们的单行日程表明天晚些时候会出来。请注意，我们正试图
to shoot Miss Angela Kinsey out next week so she can go rest easily for a full week before delivering her little girl. And to accommodate this, Wednesday through Friday schedule will be more grueling than normal, especially Friday night's work. Think Ferris wheel and fireworks. We will all take extra precautions to ensure Angela is comfortable and that she remains hydrated every single moment she is here. So prepare for the walkie talkie chatter. Angela is going 10-1 again. So yeah, I almost didn't make it to the parking lot. Well, I'm glad you made it. I am too. I do remember the whole cast and crew were a little worried. We were concerned. We wanted to make sure that we got your work done first so that you could leave. Yes. And I left and
在下周把安吉拉·金斯利小姐的戏份拍完，这样她就能在生下她的小女孩之前好好休息整整一周。为了配合这一点，周三到周五的日程会比平时更累，尤其是周五晚上的工作。想想摩天轮和烟花。我们将采取一切额外防范措施，以确保安吉拉感到舒适，并在她在这里的每一分每一秒都保持水分充足。所以准备好对讲机的聒噪吧。安吉拉又要10-1（上厕所）了。所以，是的，我差点没能去成停车场。好吧，我很高兴你去了。我也是。我确实记得整个剧组都有点担心。我们很关心。我们想确保先把你的工作做完，这样你就能离开了。是的。然后我走了，
Melissa Barker stayed. So thank you, Melissa Barker. And lady, now everyone is exiting the building, going into the parking lot. 25 minutes, 52 seconds. Ugg alert. Who has the Uggs? Who has the warm fuzzy Uggs on? Who is this person? It is me. And this starts the theme for this episode where they just gave up with me. They were like, just keep her comfortable. And I feel like in almost every shot you can see my belly and I'm wearing Uggs and no one cares. You know what? I remember watching Seinfeld when Julia Louis-Dreyfus was pregnant and there were a few times where I feel like it was the same. They were like, you know what? We all know she's pregnant. We're pretending like she's not pregnant because her character is not pregnant. Let's just,
梅丽莎·巴克留了下来。所以谢谢你，梅丽莎·巴克。女士，现在每个人都在离开大楼，走到停车场去。25分钟52秒。Ugg警报。谁穿着Ugg靴？谁穿着那双保暖毛茸茸的Ugg靴？这个人是谁？是我。而这就成了这一集的主题，他们对我都彻底放弃了。他们就像是，只要让她舒服就行。我觉得几乎在每一个镜头里都能看到我的肚子，而且我穿着Ugg靴，根本没人管。你知道吗？我记得看《宋飞正传》时，茱莉亚·路易斯-德瑞福斯怀孕了，有好几次我觉得也是这样。他们就像是，你知道吗？我们都知道她怀孕了。我们假装她没有怀孕，因为她的角色没有怀孕。让我们，
we're all in it together, folks. Yeah, we're just giving up. Exactly. Well, Michael is very disappointed that there is not an anti-gravity machine, but he is impressed with the Ferris wheel. Yeah. And there's a bouncy house, which by the way, poor Brian in the heat had to jump up and down and over and over. And it was so hot in there. And there's deleted scenes of him jumping and jumping. And it didn't even make it in the episode. I know. This is also when Pam clocks the fireworks and she realizes, oh my gosh, is Jim gonna propose tonight? She's so excited. Lady, I thought you were so good in this episode. I thought your performance was so subtle and the emotion was so there. I just thought it was a beautiful, beautiful job. Oh my gosh. Thank you
大家都在同一条船上，朋友们。是的，我们就是放弃了。没错。好吧，迈克尔对没有反重力机器感到非常失望，但他对摩天轮印象深刻。是的。还有一个充气城堡，顺便说一句，可怜的布莱恩在高温下不得不跳上跳下，一遍又一遍。里面太热了。还有他跳来跳这也是被删减的镜头。甚至都没剪进正片里。我知道。这也是帕姆注意到烟花并意识到，哦天哪，吉姆今晚要求婚了吗？她太激动了。女士，我觉得你这一集演得太好了。我觉得你的表演非常细腻，情绪非常到位。我真的觉得这是一次美丽绝伦的表演。哦天哪。非常感谢
so much. Yeah. We had a fan question from Sophie F. Did you get to go on the rides while you weren't filming? No. For insurance purposes, they were not going to let cast members who were not scripted to be on the Ferris wheel, get on the Ferris wheel. They wanted me nowhere near that thing. They were like, hey, big pregnant lady, you're already freaking us out. Stay away. I remember talking to Jen Salata about it and she said, oh my gosh, all the writers were like so excited. They're like, we're gonna ride the Ferris wheel. It's gonna be so fun. And then none of them ever wrote it. No. I remember when they had the bouncy houses, whenever we had a bouncy house, you know, there'd be someone be like, oh, could the kids come by today? They're like, nope. No one get on
你。是的。我们收到了来自苏菲·F的粉丝提问。你在不拍戏的时候能去玩那些游乐设施吗？不能。出于保险原因，他们不会让剧本里没有安排坐摩天轮的演员去坐摩天轮。他们想让我离那个东西远远的。他们就像是，嘿，大肚孕妇，你已经快把我们吓死了。离远点。我记得跟詹·萨拉塔聊过这个，她说，哦天哪，所有的编剧都兴奋极了。他们说，我们要去坐摩天轮。那一定太好玩了。然后他们谁也没去坐。没有。我记得当他们有充气城堡时，每当我们有充气城堡，你知道的，总会有人说，哦，孩子们今天能过来吗？他们说，不行。谁也不准去玩
those things. Well, two people who were allowed to get on the Ferris wheel, I remember when they shot this Angela, these poor guys, do you know how many times they had to go around that Ferris wheel? Just as a person who rode the Jurassic Park ride for 12 hours, you know how old it gets. It's a trigger for you. It is. It's a trigger. And I watched them ride that Ferris wheel for about an hour. I don't understand how they weren't completely sick. When you watch the episode, you see one scene between Michael and Holly on the Ferris wheel, but they're more and they're in the deleted scenes and they're really cute. So they were in there for a while. Yeah, I remember that. One of the Ferris wheel scenes that I love is Michael is telling Holly a story and right as
那些东西。好吧，有两个被允许去坐摩天轮的人，我记得他们拍这一场时，安吉拉，这些可怜的家伙，你知道他们绕着那个摩天轮转了多少圈吗？作为一个坐了12小时侏罗纪公园游乐设施的人，你知道这有多烦人。对你来说是个导火索。是的。是个导火索。我看着他们坐那个摩天轮坐了大约一个小时。我不明白他们怎么没有完全晕车。当你观看这一集时，你会看到迈克尔和霍莉在摩天轮上的一场戏，但还有更多，它们在被删减片段里，而且非常可爱。所以他们在上面待了一会儿。是的，我记得。我最喜欢的摩天轮场景之一是迈克尔在给霍莉讲故事，就在
they get to the top of the Ferris wheel, she shakes the cart like kind of leans forward. So it rocks and he goes, oh my God. And then they both start laughing and he's like, you got me. You know, it's so cute. It's like something Michael would have done. Yes. That probably would annoy anyone else. Yeah. Because that's an annoying thing to do. It really is. Yeah. And he's delighted by it. So cute. Well, when they finally get off the Ferris wheel, Holly catches Moe's Dwight and Meredith doing something to her car. What are you doing to my car? Well, what they're doing is putting a raccoon inside of it because they're still hazing her. Yeah. And you guys might be curious. Why is Meredith involved with Dwight and Moses hazing? We learned in a deleted scene that Meredith is
他们到达摩天轮顶端时，她摇晃了一下车厢，有点向前倾。所以它晃动了一下，他说，哦天哪。然后他们两个都笑了起来，他说，你把我整蛊了。你知道，这太可爱了。这就像迈克尔会做的事。是的。那可能会惹恼其他人。是的，因为那是一件很烦人的事。确实是。是的。而他为此感到高兴。太可爱了。好吧，当他们终于从摩天轮上下来时，霍莉撞见摩斯、德怀特和梅雷迪思对她的车做了什么。你们在对我的车做什么？好吧，他们做的是把一只浣熊放进车里，因为他们还在整蛊她。是的。你们可能会好奇。为什么梅雷迪思会参与德怀特和摩斯的整蛊？我们在一段被删减的场景中了解到，梅雷迪思
not a fan of Holly. Can you guys play the clip? I think that makes us neighbors. It's a couple streets over. Oh, maybe you can show me some of the fun hangouts or where to get my nails done. Sure. That sounds fun. Great. I hate that bitch. I want to cut her face. It just comes out of nowhere. Holly is like, Hey, I think we're neighbors. Maybe we could do stuff together. And then immediately as she walks away, Meredith is like, I hate that bitch. And Dwight overhears this and he's like, aha, I have an accomplice. And there's all these really fun scenes between Dwight and Meredith as they plan out all these different pranks. They're great. They're on the DVD. And I texted with Kate because in the script, there's some direction I want to read to you.
并不是霍莉的粉丝。你们能播放这段剪辑吗？我想这让我们成为邻居了。就在几个街区之外。哦，也许你能带我去一些好玩的地方逛逛，或者告诉我哪里可以做指甲。当然。听起来不错。太棒了。我讨厌那个贱人。我想割她的脸。这简直突如其来。霍莉就像是，嘿，我想我们是邻居。也许我们可以一起做点什么。然后就在她走开的瞬间，梅雷迪思就说，我讨厌那个贱人。德怀特无意中听到了这话，他心想，啊哈，我找到同谋了。德怀特和梅雷迪思在策划所有这些不同的恶作剧时，有许多非常有趣的场景。它们太棒了。都在DVD里。我给凯特发了短信，因为在剧本里，有一些我想读给你们听的导演说明。
It says, Michael leads Holly away in the background. Dwight casually opens Holly's car door, releasing the badger. Then there's an asterix. And it says the raccoon instantly attacks Meredith. So I was like, is it a badger or is it a raccoon? But either way, I texted Kate and I said, did you have to film getting attacked by a raccoon? Jen Salata said the original outline for the script had them putting a badger in the car instead of a raccoon. But they couldn't find a trained badger to attack Meredith. Well, who knew? So Kent got a raccoon from this place called Critters of the Cinema. But then they realized that even a raccoon is not really trained well enough for an attack scene, at least not to the point where they felt like they wanted Kate to have a raccoon on her.
上面写着，迈克尔带着霍莉在背景中走开。德怀特漫不经心地打开霍莉的车门，放出了獾。然后有一个星号。上面写着浣熊瞬间袭击了梅雷迪思。所以我当时想，到底是獾还是浣熊？但不管怎样，我给凯特发短信说，你得拍被浣熊袭击的戏吗？詹·萨拉塔说，剧本最初的大纲是让他们在车里放一只獾而不是浣熊。但他们找不到受过训练的獾来袭击梅雷迪思。好吧，谁知道呢？所以肯特从一个叫“电影动物”的地方弄来了一只浣熊。但后来他们意识到，甚至连浣熊也没有受过足够的训练来拍袭击戏，至少没有达到他们希望凯特身边真的有一只浣熊的程度。
Yeah. So they hired a stunt double to do it. But then they realized the best way to do it was maybe with CGI. So they did a shot of Kate just flailing around as if she was being attacked by a raccoon. But in the end, the whole thing got cut. Yeah. However, Kate said that there is a scene later where she has scratch marks on her face. Yeah, I texted Kate and she said they filmed her screaming and running around. Then they didn't end up using any of it. And she said once again, the animals have better representation than me. Very funny. Because she always gets roped into these animal attacks. I found an old interview that Mike sure did as Moe's talking about the raccoon. Oh, yeah? This is what Moe's has to say about it. Quote, I love the raccoon. The raccoon's name is
是的。所以他们雇了一个特技替身来做这件事。但后来他们意识到最好的做法可能是用CGI特效。所以他们拍了一个凯特四处乱挥手挣扎的镜头，就好像她正被一只浣熊袭击一样。但最后，整段戏都被剪掉了。是的。不过，凯特说后面有一个场景，她的脸上有抓痕。是的，我给凯特发了短信，她说他们拍了她尖叫和四处奔跑的镜头。然后他们根本没用上。她还说，动物的代表权再次比她好了。太搞笑了。因为她总是被卷入这些动物袭击事件中。我找到了一段迈克·舒尔以前作为摩斯谈论浣熊的采访。哦，是吗？这是摩斯对它的评价。引述，我爱这只浣熊。这只浣熊的名字叫
Cher, because when I found him, he was eating a chair. He has a brother named Trampoline Leg. Cher is very nice. I made sure Cher got home safely. Cher would never hurt anyone except once Cher bit my cheek when I was feeding him a lemon. End quote. Moe's the conversationalist. Michael really comes to Holly's defense, you know? He tells them they should be ashamed of themselves and that that Holly is the best thing to happen to this company since World War II. And she is going to be so appreciative that she touches Michael's arm and it kind of lingers there for a second. For a second, I counted. Nine seconds. Count that out. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine. Come on. That's a lingering touch right there.
雪儿（Cher），因为当我发现它时，它正在吃一把椅子。它有一个兄弟叫“蹦床腿”。雪儿非常可爱。我确保雪儿安全回家了。雪儿绝不会伤害任何人，除了有一次我喂它吃柠檬时，雪儿咬了我的脸颊。引述结束。话唠摩斯。迈克尔真的在为霍莉辩护，你知道吗？他告诉他们应该为自己感到羞耻，霍莉是自第二次世界大战以来发生在这家公司最好的事情。她感动得触摸了迈克尔的手臂，并且在那里停留了一秒钟。一秒钟，我数了。九秒钟。数出来。一，二，三，四，五，六，七，八，九。拜托。那绝对是依依不舍的触摸。
This talking head broke my heart. He's so excited. This is so good. He says, did you see that? Did you see that? He's kind of talking to the documentarian crew, right? He's like, you know, Jan didn't believe in affection. So sometimes he just doesn't know how to react when a girl touches him, but he really likes it. Holly is so perfect for him. I know. But there's a problem at the party, Angela. I'm sorry to tell you the barbecue sauce is out. Oh, yeah. By the way, do you know who's doing the barbecuing? It's Gino and Leo from Vance Refrigeration, played by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberger, two writers. They were perfect as those guys. I don't know if that's a compliment or not, but
这段访谈让我心碎。他太激动了。这太棒了。他说，你看到了吗？你看到了吗？他有点像在跟纪录片摄制组说话，对吧？他说，你知道，简不相信温情。所以有时当一个女孩触摸他时，他只是不知道该如何反应，但他真的很喜欢。霍莉太适合他了。我知道。但派对上出了点问题，安吉拉。我很遗憾地告诉你，烧烤酱用完了。哦，是的。顺便问一下，你知道是谁在烧烤吗？是来自万斯冷冻的吉诺和利奥，由编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格饰演。他们演这两个家伙简直绝了。我不知道这算不算夸奖，不过
they were great as those two idiots. Well, Phyllis tells Kevin you need to go get more barbecue sauce. Well, guess what? There was a deleted scene where Angela is like, Phyllis, I got it. No problem. And she's like, really? She's like, yeah, I'll get the barbecue sauce. Don't worry about it. And Phyllis is like, oh, okay, thanks. And then Angela never goes and gets the barbecue sauce. And then Phyllis goes, hey, Angela, they really need the barbecue sauce. And I said, oh, oops, I forgot. Now you know what it's like to work with someone who's an incompetent assistant. Phyllis is like so ticked. And that's when she goes to Kevin and says, Kevin, can you go get the barbecue sauce? So there's a lot of deleted Phyllis and Angela in this episode
他们演这两个白痴演得真好。好吧，菲利斯告诉凯文你需要去拿更多烧烤酱。好吧，你猜怎么着？有一个被删减的场景，安吉拉说，菲利斯，我来。没问题。然后菲利斯说，真的吗？她说，对，我去拿烧烤酱。别担心。菲利斯说，哦，好吧，谢谢。然后安吉拉根本没去拿烧烤酱。然后菲利斯说，嘿，安吉拉，他们真的很需要烧烤酱。我说，哦，哎呀，我忘了。现在你知道和这样一个不称职的助手一起工作是什么感觉了。菲利斯气坏了。这就是她去找凯文说“凯文，你能去拿一下烧烤酱吗”的原因。所以这一集里有很多被删减的菲利斯和安吉拉的对手戏，
that really, really ratchets up Phyllis's pissed offness towards Angela. You know what that is from Angela? That's some sandwich right there. Sabotage. Sabotage. Yeah. It's time for Michael's big speech. There can't really be a party without a speech from Michael, right? Except it's not just a speech. He's going to sing for us, guys. Oh, wait, wait. First of all, he makes a huge thank you to Phyllis for throwing the best party they've ever had. At 29, 22 seconds, this might be the biggest Angela eye roll of the whole entire series. Yeah. It's a full body eye roll. Angela, I'm going to say something to you right now, and you're just going to have to hear it. What? He's not wrong. This is the best party. It's the best party. Okay, fine. Outside of maybe
大大加剧了菲利斯对安吉拉的怒火。你知道安吉拉那是什幺行为吗？那是实打实的叛变啊。蓄意破坏。蓄意破坏。是的。是时候发表迈克尔的慷慨陈词了。没有迈克尔的演讲，派对就不算完整，对吧？不过这不仅仅是一场演讲。伙计们，他要为我们唱歌。哦，等等，等等。首先，他大大感谢了菲利斯举办了他们有史以来最好的派对。在29分22秒，这可能是整部剧里最大的一次安吉拉翻白眼了。是的。这是一个全身心的翻白眼。安吉拉，我现在要对你说一句话，你只能听着。什么？他说得没错。这是最好的派对。这是最好的派对。好吧，好吧。除了也许
Casino Night where I think maybe Michael hired, you know, a professional party committee or something, but for a homemade office party Phyllis nailed it. It's great. She did. She nailed it. What you guys don't even know because it's in deleted scenes is there were corn dogs that made Stanley and Oscar happy. There were deep fried Twinkies. I mean, there were all kinds of things happening here. And during this speech, thanking Phyllis, Michael is going to go on to say, Hey, Toby, why don't you come up here? Give a farewell speech. Toby doesn't want to. Michael forces him to. It's a deleted scene. It's delicious. You got to hear Toby's farewell speech. Toby is written a fantastic speech for you. He spent a year on it. It's very funny and charming
赌场之夜，我觉得迈克尔可能雇了什么专业派对委员会之类的，但对于一个自制的办公室派对来说，菲利斯真是绝了。太棒了。她确实做到了。她办得太棒了。你们甚至不知道的是，因为在被删减的场景里，有玉米热狗让斯坦利和奥斯卡很开心。还有油炸甜甜圈。我的意思是，这里发生了各种各样的事情。在这篇感谢菲利斯的演讲中，迈克尔接着说，嘿，托比，你为什么不上来发表个告别演讲呢？托比不想去。迈克尔强迫他去。这是一段被删减的场景。太美味了。你们得听听托比的告别演讲。托比为你写了一篇精彩的演讲。他花了一年时间写的。非常有趣、迷人、
and heartwarming and it rhymes. And if it's not any good, he has instructed us all to storm the stage and beat him to a bloody pulp. So take it away, Toby. Well, okay. It's really great to be here tonight. Yeah. Ferris wheel, band, the low sunlight. I'm going to miss you all when I go to Costa Rica. And if I keep drinking beer like this, I'm going to have to take a lika. Yeah. Like on a more personal note, I just want to say thanks, you know, no matter what was going on in my life, you know, my divorce or the custody battle or that thing with my sister. It was just nice knowing I had a supportive place to come to where I'm going to really miss going to beers with you guys every Tuesday night. And lastly, I'd love to urge you to
温馨而且押韵。如果它写得不好，他已经指示我们所有人冲上台去把他打成肉酱。所以，有请托比。嗯，好吧。今晚能来到这里真的很棒。是的，摩天轮，乐队，低矮的阳光。当我要去哥斯达黎加时，我会想念你们所有人的。如果我继续这样喝啤酒，我得去上个厕所了。是的。就像，说到更私人的事，我只想说谢谢，你知道的，不管我生活发生了什么，你知道的，我的离婚或者抚养权之战，或者我姐姐的那件事。能知道我有一个支持我的地方可以来，真是太好了，我真的会很想念你们每周二晚上一起去喝啤酒的时光。最后，我想要敦促你们
keep up with my fight to have the building checked for a raid on gas. You know, it's a real serious matter. And every time I try to overstate your welcome, let's keep it moving. Let's keep it moving. Toby, everybody. Okay, Angela, I remember filming that. And I especially remember the part when he says how much he loved going out for beers with us every Tuesday night and the look on Michael's face. Michael's like, wait, what? People go out for drinks every Tuesday. Michael has clearly never been invited to beers on Tuesday. No. And then I love Toby's last thing with this plea about the raid. Yes, which is by the way going to play out all the way until season nine. I know. It's so good. So Michael is going to sing for Toby. He's going to sing a parody
继续我要求检测大楼里是否有氡气的斗争。你知道，这是一件非常严重的事。每次我试图自讨没趣，让我们继续吧。让我们继续。托比，大家。好的，安吉拉，我记得拍摄那一幕的情景。我尤其记得他说他有多么喜欢我们每周二晚上一起出去喝啤酒的那一部分，以及迈克尔脸上的表情。迈克尔的表情就像是，等等，什么？人们每周二都出去喝酒？迈克尔显然从来没有被邀请去参加周二的啤酒之夜。没有。然后我喜欢托比关于氡气的最后那个请求。是的，顺便说一句，这个梗一直延续到了第九季。我知道。太棒了。所以迈克尔要为托比唱歌。他要唱一首恶搞歌曲
of Goodbye Stranger called Goodbye Toby. We had a fan question from Stephanie Claire Yvette and Ashley who said, who wrote the amazing parody song Goodbye Toby? Guys, Paul Lieberstein. Paul Lieberstein wrote the lyrics to his own character's Goodbye parody song. But in this speech, Michael says, you guys know I'm an accomplished songwriter. Mm-hmm. To which Pam, under her breath, says a parody songwriter. Yes. And he mentions two of the other songs he's famous for are Beers in Heaven and Total Eclipse of the Fart. I went online and I found this old interview that Paul Lieberstein did where he revealed the lyrics for Beers in Heaven and Total Eclipse of the Fart. And we might have done something with those lyrics. Angela,
名为“再见托比”（Goodbye Stranger，注：实为Goodbye Toby）。我们收到了来自斯蒂芬妮、克莱尔、伊薇特和阿什利的粉丝提问，他们问：谁写了那首精彩的恶搞歌曲《再见托比》？伙计们，是保罗·利伯施泰因。保罗·利伯施泰因给他自己角色的恶搞歌曲《再见托比》写了歌词。但在这段演讲中，迈克尔说，你们知道我是个很有成就的词曲作家。嗯哼。帕姆在一旁小声说：是个恶搞词曲作家。是的。并且他提到他另外两首成名曲是《天堂里的啤酒》（Beers in Heaven）和《屁的日食》（Total Eclipse of the Fart）。我上网找到了一篇保罗·利伯施泰因的旧采访，他在采访中透露了《天堂里的啤酒》和《屁的节食》（注：应为《屁的日食》）的歌词。我们可能用这些歌词做了一些事情。安吉拉，
do you want to tell everybody? We did. When Jenna emailed our group here that she found the original lyrics, we got so tickled. So I asked my husband, Josh, who was the a cappella guy in college, a ca-what? Oh yeah, that was Josh. And Josh sings Beers in Heaven. Would you drink a beer if you saw it in heaven? Would it taste the same if you drank a leaven? I love it. I love it. That was just a little window into Josh's karaoke evenings. His voice is so good. He's really got a good voice. But Beers in Heaven, getting to really hear it in all of its beauty. I loved it. I laughed so hard. I loved every minute. And Jenna, one of the sound engineers at Earwolf, Jordan Duffy, is going to sing Total Eclipse of
你想告诉大家吗？我们确实这么做了。当珍娜给我们的群发邮件说她找到了原版歌词时，我们觉得太逗了。所以我问了我丈夫乔什，他在大学时是个阿卡贝拉（无伴奏合唱）达人，阿卡什么？哦，对，那就是乔什。乔什演唱了《天堂里的啤酒》。如果你在天堂看到啤酒，你会喝一杯吗？如果你喝了发酵的啤酒，味道会和以前一样吗？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。这只是对乔什卡拉OK之夜的一个小小窥探。他的声音太棒了。他真的有一副好嗓子。但《天堂里的啤酒》，真正听到它所有的美妙之处。我太喜欢了。我笑得前仰后合。我喜欢每一个时刻。还有珍娜，Earwolf的一个音响工程师，乔丹·达菲，将演唱
the Fart. Now she did an inspired version off of what Paul wrote. She might have added in some fart sounds. Let's hear it. And I need to fart forever. And I need to fart tonight. And I need to fart forever. And if you'll only put my finger, we'll be smelling fart together. I need to fart tonight. And I need to fart forever. And I need to fart. Every now and then, I cut a fart. Well done, guys. Thank you so much for bringing these Michael Parody songs to life. You know, I have to say, especially Total Eclipse of the Fart, it really took me back. Do you remember the Dan
《屁的日食》。现在她根据保罗写的内容创作了一个充满灵感的版本。她可能加入了一些放屁的声音。我们来听听吧。我需要永远放屁。我今晚需要放屁。我需要永远放屁。如果你只要把我的手指放上来，我们就能一起闻到屁味。我今晚需要放屁。我需要永远放屁。我需要放屁。时不时地，我放个屁。干得好，伙计们。非常感谢你们让这些迈克尔的恶搞歌曲重现生机。你知道，我不得不说，特别是《屁的日食》，真的把我带回了过去。还记得丹
Band? Yes. I freaking love the Dan Band. I saw them live many times. Guys, you know that Adam Sandler movie, The Wedding Singer? The Dan Band is featured in The Wedding Singer. And they are just like this amazing cover band. They do all these hits from the 80s. But you know, they kind of curse through them and stuff. And they put all these comedy bits in them. And they actually do a Total Eclipse of the Fart that is a showstopper. Check it out on YouTube. You'll love it. I love it. That's what it made me think of. I love it. Well, we also got a fan question from Carolyn W. and Ashley W. Who are the other musicians in Darrell's band? Oh, great question. Are they the same band from Booze Cruise? No. The band from
乐队吗？记得。我超级喜欢丹乐队。我现场看过他们很多次。伙计们，你们知道亚当·桑德勒的那部电影《婚礼歌手》吗？丹乐队在《婚礼歌手》里出场了。他们就像是一个超级棒的翻唱乐队。他们演唱所有这些80年代的热门歌曲。但你知道的，他们会在歌里爆粗口之类的一边唱一边过。而且他们还在里面加入了所有这些喜剧桥段。他们实际上演唱的《屁的日食》是一个能惊艳全场的节目。去YouTube上看看吧。你会喜欢的。我喜欢。这就是让我想起它的原因。我喜欢。好吧，我们还收到了卡罗琳·W和阿什利·W的粉丝提问。达瑞尔乐队里的其他乐手是谁？哦，好问题。他们是《酒船派对》里那个乐队吗？不是。《酒船派对》里
Booze Cruise is different. The guys in this band were the guys in Craig Robinson's real band in real life. Oh, that's great. On bass is his brother, Chris Rob. The drummer is Asa Watkins. And David Sampson is on guitar. And I remember Angela Steve did a lot of improvising during this scene. He did one whole bit where he danced. He took a big dance break during one of them. He took the guitar and like did a full on guitar solo. It was amazing. They had so much to choose from. Was any of that stuff in the deleted scenes? No, it wasn't. Oh, I know. But there's so much there. There's footage of Steve just going off and on a crazy hot day in a suit. And he is just fricking giving Toby the send off of the year. I was hot just sitting and watching it. I can't
的乐队是另一支。这个乐队里的家伙们是克雷格·罗宾逊在现实生活中的真实乐队成员。哦，那太棒了。贝斯手是他弟弟克里斯·罗布。鼓手是阿萨·沃特金斯。大卫·桑普森担任吉他手。我记得安吉拉，史蒂夫在这场戏中有很多即兴发挥。他有一整段都在跳舞。其中一段他来了一段精彩的舞蹈大爆发。他拿过吉他，就像来了一段完全的吉他独奏。太惊艳了。他们有太多东西可以选了。这些东西有出现在被删减片段里吗？没有，没有。哦，我知道。但那里有太多东西了。有史蒂夫在炎热潮湿的日子里穿着西装疯狂狂飙的镜头。他只是在给托比送上年度最赞的欢送。我光是坐着看就觉得热。我无法
imagine what that was like for Steve. But when I was watching this with Lee, he said one of his favorite things about this episode was the way we had that harsh back sun beating down on Steve and all of us. He said, I've been at those things. I've been at those company events and you're hot and you're sitting at the little table and we're all having to like cover our eyes even to see. Yes. He thought that was so great. And he pointed out so many times in television and movies. They don't do that. They don't have like that harsh beating sun. Oh no, they'll tarp things or they'll like shoot at that golden hour where everyone looks amazing and no one has to squint. He thought it was a real nod to the authenticity of the documentary style of the
想象对史蒂夫来说那是什么感觉。但当我跟李一起看这一集时，他说他关于这一集最喜欢的事情之一，就是那种灼热的夕阳照在史蒂夫和我们所有人身上的方式。他说，我经历过那种事。我经历过那种公司活动，天气很热，你坐在小桌子旁，我们甚至都得用手挡住眼睛才能看清。是的。他觉得这太棒了。而且他指出在电视剧和电影中很多次。他们不会那样做。他们不会有那种刺眼的烈日。哦，不，他们会搭天幕，或者他们会选择在黄金时刻拍摄，那时每个人看起来都状态极佳，谁也不用眯着眼睛。他认为这是对该剧纪录片风格真实感的一次真正致敬。当时我就想，哦天哪，你说得对。
show. And I was like, oh my gosh, you're right. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know, your husband's looking at it with a director's eye and that's such a great catch. And there is a talking head in the script that's not in the deleted scenes where after this whole crazy performance, Michael's like, you know what, I've just got to sweat Toby out. Sweating him out. Well, Pam has a very sweet talking head. She says that she's going to miss Toby because he was a calming presence in the office. And then if only Toby could hear, she says, don't tell him I said this, but I always thought he was kind of cute. Oh, you know, years later, Toby's going to see this and like fall off his chair. Oh my gosh. Well, there's a series of deleted talking heads where people sort of
没错。没错。好吧，你知道的，你丈夫是从导演的角度来看待这一点的，这真是个绝妙的发现。剧本里还有一个删减片段里没有的访谈镜头（Talking Head），在整场疯狂的表演之后，迈克尔说，你知道吗，我得把托比的汗给“蒸”出来。把他的汗蒸出来。好吧，帕姆有一个非常温馨的访谈镜头。她说她会想念托比，因为他是办公室里一个令人安心的存在。然后，如果托比能听见的话，她说，别告诉他我这么说过，但我一直觉得他挺可爱的。哦，你知道的，多年以后，托比看到这个会从椅子上摔下来。哦天哪。好吧，有一系列被删减的访谈镜头，人们在其中谈论他们与托比的关系，他们会对托比有什么记忆。但剧本里有一个没有进入被删减片段的镜头，我必须和你们分享。那是奥斯卡。他说，
talk about their relationship to Toby, what they'll remember about Toby. But there's one in the script that didn't make it to the deleted scenes that I have to share with you. It's Oscar. And he says, well, the finer things club is going to have a spot to fill. Our candidates are Kevin Stanley, Angela Kelly, Meredith Creed. We may have to change it to just the things club. Oh, because of one of those people joints that they're not going to be finer anymore. That's right. That's right. Oh, listening to that list, I don't want to be in a club with any of those people. Oh, truly, none of them is going to take the material seriously.
好吧，“精致生活俱乐部”将有一个空缺要填补。我们的候选人是凯文·斯坦利、安吉拉·凯利、梅丽塔·克里德（注：此处为角色名混搭恶搞）。我们可能不得不把它改名为“只是生活俱乐部”了。哦，因为其中那些人的关节（注：指发福），他们不再那么精致了。没错。没错。哦，听了那个名单，我才不想和那些人中的任何一个在同一个俱乐部里。哦，真的，他们中没有人会认真对待这些材料。
Are there going to have too many objections? Angela's going to not want to read half the books you want to read. I know. All right. Well, there's a very cute Michael Holly flirty flirt scene. She's saying she'd love to hear beers in heaven. And he's like, Hey, too soon, kind of sexual. During this whole conversation in the background, 31 minutes, 19 seconds, you can see Stanley and he's dancing by the band. It's so cute. Amazing. Well, during this scene, Michael gets a phone call from Kevin, who's at the supermarket and says, you need to get down here immediately, immediately. So Michael's like, all right, when he gets to the supermarket, he finds out why Kevin called him. Jan is there.
他们会有太多的反对意见吗？安吉拉不会想读你想读的一半的书。我知道。好吧，好吧，有一个非常可爱的迈克尔和霍莉调情的场景。她说她很想听《天堂里的啤酒》。他说，嘿，太快了，有点色情。在背景中的整个对话期间，在31分19秒时，你可以看到斯坦利在乐队旁边跳舞。太可爱了。太棒了。好吧，在这个场景中，迈克尔接到了凯文的电话，凯文在超市里说，你得马上来这里，马上。所以迈克尔说，好吧，当他到达超市时，他发现了凯文叫他来的原因。珍在那儿。
Mm-hmm. And Jan is pregnant. Yeah, pregnant. Jan plus one is there. Fan question from Dorothy Jay, was Malora Harden actually pregnant or was it a fake belly? It was a fake belly. Malora has two daughters, but they were very much born by this point. Very much born. They were. They were not in the belly anymore. No. No. Jan and Michael are going to catch up. Yeah. Michael is so happy. He's deliriously happy. But Jan says you're not the father. No. And Michael says you cheated on me when I specifically asked you not to. He also shares that they were very cautious and he had to wear two condoms. Yeah. But the timing, it's clear that this pregnancy happened while they were still together. And
嗯哼。而且珍怀孕了。对，怀孕了。珍加一在那里。多萝西·J的粉丝提问，梅洛拉·哈丁是真的怀孕了还是假的假肚子？是个假肚子。梅洛拉有两个女儿，但到这个时候她们早就出生了。早就出生了。是的。她们不在肚子里了。不。不。珍和迈克尔要叙叙旧了。对。迈克尔太高兴了。他高兴得神魂颠倒。但珍说你不是孩子的父亲。不。迈克尔说你在我特地要求你不要这么做的情况下背叛了我。他还分享说他们当时非常谨慎，他不得不戴两个安全套。对。但从时间上看，很明显这次怀孕发生在他俩还在一起的时候。并且
she explains that is true. We were together. Mm-hmm. But I went to a sperm bank. A really good one, not just any sperm bank. It's the really, really good one next to the IHOP. Yeah. Jenna in the script and it didn't make it to the deleted scenes. Jan reveals who's sperm she bought. What? Yeah. Who's sperm is it? Jan says you have to pay top dollar, but it's worth it. Now, here's the best part. I got Andy Roddick's sperm. What? Yeah. And Jan looks to Michael like she's expecting him to be very impressed. And Michael says the tennis player. And Jan says, well, it's a little more than that. He's the sixth ranked player in the world and he's won four grand slams. And Michael says, that's a lot of grand slams, I guess. And Jan says, and he's a humanitarian,
她解释说这是真的。我们当时在一起。嗯哼。但我去了精子库。一个非常好的精子库，不只是随便什么精子库。就是IHOP（国际煎饼屋）旁边那个真的非常非常好的精子库。对。珍娜，剧本里有但没有进入被删减片段的内容，珍透露了她买谁的精子。什么？对。是谁的精子？珍说你得花大钱，但物有所值。现在，最棒的部分来了。我买了安迪·罗迪克的精子。什么？对。而且珍看着迈克尔的表情，好像期望他会留下深刻印象。迈克尔说那个网球运动员。珍说，嗯，不仅如此。他是世界排名第六的球员，他还赢过四个大满贯。迈克尔说，我想那有很多大满贯。珍说，而且他是一个人道主义者，
something with orphans. And Michael is quiet. And Jan goes, Michael, and Michael says, can I just sit here for a minute without more things coming into my head? Okay. You guys, Andy Roddick was friends with Rainn Wilson and he was a big fan of the office and he came by the set. I have to imagine that the reason they wrote it as being Andy Roddick's sperm was a little bit of a nod to Andy, who has an amazing sense of humor. Me and Lee got to know Andy and Brooklyn through our love of tennis. We would go watch Andy play tennis and sit with Brooklyn. And oh my gosh, I am so sad for his sake that this did not stay in the episode because... I know. I got to know Brooklyn myself through some charity work and I was like, I kind of want to text her this couplet of dialogue. I
跟孤儿有关的事。迈克尔沉默了。珍说，迈克尔，迈克尔说，我能不能就这么坐一会儿，别再有别的东西涌进我脑子里了？好吧。伙计们，安迪·罗迪克是雷恩·威尔逊的朋友，他还是办公室的超级粉丝，他来过片场。我不得不猜测，他们把它写成是安迪·罗迪克的精子的原因，是对安迪的一点小致敬，他有着惊人的幽默感。我和李通过对网球的热爱认识了安迪和布鲁克林。我们会去看安迪打网球，和布鲁克林坐在一起。哦天哪，我真为他感到遗憾，这段内容没有留在这一集里，因为……我知道。我和布鲁克林通过一些慈善工作认识了，当时我就想，我挺想给她发短信分享这几句台词的。我当时
was cracking up. So Andy Roddick is the father of Jan's baby. Incredible. Incredible. Anyway, that's in the shooting draft. It didn't make it to the screen or the deleted scenes, but I thought that was hilarious and I had to share. Well, Jan tells Michael, I'm so happy I've gotten this off my chest. And by the way, if you want to come to my Lamaze class, I'd love to have you there. But Michael says, I need to think about it. I need to think about it. And he has this talking head where he says his whole life he's known two things. He loves sex and he wants to have kids. He always thought those things would go hand in hand, but you know, now it's one or the other. So Michael does this talking head standing outside of the supermarket and we put up a sign
笑疯了。所以安迪·罗迪克是珍孩子的父亲。难以置信。难以置信。不管怎样，那是拍摄初稿里的内容。它没有出现在正片或被删减片段中，但我认为这太搞笑了，我必须分享。好吧，珍告诉迈克尔，我很高兴我把这块心病说出来了。顺便说一句，如果你想来我的拉玛泽（分娩呼吸法）课程，我很乐意你来。但迈克尔说，我得考虑一下。我得考虑一下。他有一个访谈镜头，他说他一生中知道两件事：他喜欢性，他想生孩子。他一直以为这两件事会相辅相成，但你知道，现在只能二选一了。所以迈克尔在超市外面站着做了一个访谈镜头，我们挂了一个牌子
that it was a Garrity's supermarket. And that is a real supermarket, a family-run grocery store chain in Pennsylvania. And I looked it up, Angela, and it was so charming and amazing. Yeah. You go to their website and you can click on this thing on their website that says, who is mom? Who is mom? I was intrigued. I clicked. And it explains that Garrity's is run by Joyce Mom Fasula. She is the president and CEO of Garrity's. That's why their slogan is, Garrity's where mom's in charge. She was born in 1947 in Scranton. She graduated from Maywood University with a master's in counseling and education. And she was a teacher at North Pocono School District. Then in 1971, she married Neil Fasula and he ran the family grocery business.
说那是一家加里蒂（Garrity's）超市。那是一家真正的超市，宾夕法尼亚州的一家家族经营的杂货店连锁店。我查了一下，安吉拉，它太迷人太惊艳了。对。你访问他们的网站，你可以在他们的网站上点击一个名为“谁是妈妈？”的东西。谁是妈妈？我很感兴趣。我点击了。它解释说加里蒂是由乔伊斯·“妈妈”·法苏拉（Joyce Mom Fasula）经营的。她是加里蒂的总裁兼首席执行官。这就是为什么他们的标语是，加里蒂，妈妈说了算。她1947年出生于斯克兰顿。她毕业于梅伍德大学，获得咨询与教育硕士学位。她曾是北波科诺学区的老师。然后在1971年，她嫁给了尼尔·法苏拉，他经营着家族杂货生意。
She left teaching to raise her two sons. But when her husband Neil passed away in 1997, she took over the grocery business. Garrity's is the largest family owned supermarket business in Northeastern Pennsylvania. And it is one of the largest in the country that is owned by a mom. But wait, there's more. Okay. Perhaps you'd like to click on the button titled, who is Aunt Mary? Who is Aunt Mary? Well, Aunt Mary is Joyce's mother-in-law, Mary Fasula. And long before her son Neil started the grocery business, Mary would make all of her family recipes and sell them to local businesses and restaurants in Scranton. She made pasta, sauces, meatballs and Italian cookies. When people asked who made this, the shop owners would say, oh, that's our Aunt Mary.
她辞去教职来抚养两个儿子。但当她的丈夫尼尔于1997年去世时，她接管了杂货生意。加里蒂是宾夕法尼亚州东北部最大的家族式连锁超市企业。这也是全国由母亲拥有的最大连锁企业之一。但等等，还有呢。好吧。也许你想点击标有“谁是玛丽阿姨？”的按钮。谁是玛丽阿姨？好吧，玛丽阿姨是乔伊斯的婆婆玛丽·法苏拉。早在她的儿子尼尔开始杂货生意之前，玛丽就会制作所有的家庭秘方，并将它们卖给斯克兰顿的本地企业和餐馆。她制作意大利面、酱汁、肉丸和意大利饼干。当人们问这是谁做的时，店主会说，哦，那是我们的玛丽阿姨。
Well, the name stuck. And when her son started his grocery business, she started a brand called Aunt Mary's Kitchen and they sold her stuff at the grocery store. And I'll have you know, I looked it up. They still sell her Italian cookies in the bakery and they still sell her meatballs and stuffing in the deli. I love it. I went on their website as well. I love the whole story, how it started in 1895 with William Garrity. And then Neil Fasula started working there as a delivery boy in the 60s. It's just been a family owned business passed down. And I want to go there. Let's put it on the tour list. Let's put it on the tour list. I want to meet mom. I want to meet mom. Guys, back at the party, the fireworks have started. They're very exciting, very romantic.
好吧，这个名字就流传下来了。当她的儿子开始他的杂货生意时，她创立了一个名为“玛丽阿姨的厨房”的品牌，他们在杂货店里出售她的东西。我得告诉你们，我查过了。他们仍然在面包店出售她的意大利饼干，他们仍然在熟食店出售她的肉丸和填料。我太喜欢了。我也上了他们的网站。我喜欢整个故事，它始于1895年的威廉·加里蒂。然后尼尔·法苏拉在60年代开始在那里做送货男孩。这只是一项代代相传的家族企业。我想去那里。把它加入巡回清单吧。把它加入巡回清单。我想见妈妈。我想见妈妈。伙计们，回到派对上，烟花开始了。它们非常激动人心，非常浪漫。
We got a fan question from Hudson M. Were the fireworks real or were they special effects? They were real. Mm hmm. Kentopedia told me we spent, are you ready for it? Oh no, how much money? $11,000. How much? $11,000 on the fireworks. Holy moly. Yeah. And we launched them in the field where we used to have like overflow parking. We cleared out the parking lot and that's where they shot them off. So the fireworks are going off. People are impressed, except Angela Martin, who tells Phyllis she will never plan another party again. Why not? It was a great party. Ease up, Angela. She's not having it. Guys, Jim gets the ring out of his pocket. He's holding it. He's hiding it. He's about to propose. This is going to be amazing. And I'm going to make us take
我们收到了哈德逊·M的粉丝提问。烟花是真的还是特效？是真的。嗯哼。肯托百科（Kentopedia）告诉我我们花了——你们准备好了吗？哦不，花了多少钱？1万1千美元。多少？花在烟花上1万1千美元。天哪。是的。我们在以前用作溢出停车场的田地里发射的。我们清理了停车场，那就是他们发射烟花的地方。所以烟花绽放了。人们印象深刻，除了安吉拉·马丁，她告诉菲利斯她再也不会策划任何派对了。为什么不呢？这是一个很棒的派对。放轻松，安吉拉。她才不买账呢。伙计们，吉姆把戒指从口袋里拿出来了。他拿着它。他藏着它。他正要求婚。这会非常棒。我要让我们休息一下。
a break. We'll tell you what happens in just a second. Okay, guys, we're back. Remember, Jim's got a ring in his hand. He's going to propose. He's going to do it. He's going to do it. And then and then Andy grabs the microphone. His parents are there. There's fireworks. This is the moment. All right, we had a fan question from Genesee and Chelsea B. There are a lot of spoilers in this. So if for some reason you've not seen the whole series, just fast forward 15 seconds. Here's what they have to say. What is the deal with Andy's family? When we see Andy's parents again in season eight garden party, they are different actors, and they have different names. This is true. In season six, Andy says if it weren't for secretaries, he wouldn't have a stepmom.
我们一会儿就告诉你们发生了什么。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。记住，吉姆手里拿着一枚戒指。他要向她求婚。他要行动了。他要行动了。然后——然后安迪抓起了麦克风。他的父母都在现场。有烟花。这就是时刻。好吧，我们收到了来自杰内西和切尔西·B的粉丝提问。这里有很多剧透。所以如果由于某种原因你还没有看过整部剧，只需快进15秒。以下是他们要说的。安迪的家人是怎么回事？当我们第八季的《花园派对》中再次看到安迪的父母时，他们是不同的演员，而且他们有不同的名字。这是真的。在第六季中，安迪说如果不是因为秘书，他不会有继母。
In season five, Andy says there's a place his parents decided not to get divorced. So what is happening? In season nine, Andy's dad leaves with all the family money and a younger woman. And then Wikipedia says that his mom died and the woman we meet is his stepmom. But they're like, we don't remember that. They said, frankly, every time we talk about Andy's family, it's different. What is going on? Can you check the show Bible? Please, please, can you give us any clarity? I'm guessing no one entered anything in the show Bible and they kept making things up and people couldn't remember what's going on. Well, Angela, you would be correct. I talked to Jen Salata about it. She said, here's what happened. Andy's parents were seen briefly
在第五季中，安迪说有一个地方他的父母决定不离婚。所以这到底是怎么回事？在第九季中，安迪的爸爸带着所有的家庭财产和一个年轻女人私奔了。然后维基百科说他妈妈去世了，我们见到的那个女人是他的继母。但他们说，我们不记得那个了。他们说，坦率地说，每次我们谈到安迪的家人，情况都不一样。这到底是怎么回事？你能查一下剧本圣经（Show Bible）吗？求求你了，求求你了，你能给我们任何澄清吗？我猜没有人把任何东西输入剧本圣经，他们一直在编造事情，而人们记不清到底发生了什么。好吧，安吉拉，你说得对。我跟珍·萨拉塔谈过这件事。她说，事情是这样的。安迪的父母曾短暂出现在
in this episode as extras. But when it came time to bring them on for real, they had to be cast. So they had to hire actors to do these speaking roles. They held auditions. And that's why they changed. She said, as far as all of the other inconsistencies, she says, I have no idea. Just clearly we were not paying attention and we were just writing what was funniest. She said, she really believes that Genesee and Chelsea B should work in continuity. She commends their question. Yes, great job. Well, guys, since his parents are there, this set of parents, at least, he is going to propose to Angela. He asked her to come up on stage. She won't go. So he's going to drag the microphone and keyboard to her. Yeah, he's going to wreck Darrell's keyboard and go to
这一集中作为群众演员。但当真正需要让他们真人出场时，他们必须进行选角。所以他们不得不雇用演员来扮演这些有台词的角色。他们举行了试镜。这就是他们换人的原因。她说，至于所有其他的矛盾之处，她说，我不知道。很明显我们当时根本没注意，我们只是在写最好笑的东西。她说，她真的认为杰内西和切尔西·B应该去负责剧情连贯性（Continuity）。她称赞了他们的问题。是的，干得好。好吧，伙计们，既然他的父母都在，这组父母，至少是其中一组，他要向安吉拉求婚了。他请她上台。她不肯上去。所以他要把麦克风和键盘拖到她那里去。是的，他要把达瑞尔的键盘弄坏，去找
his lady. Yeah, you can see my belly in this shot. Oh, for sure. In this whole scene, I'm just pregnant and no one cares. I loved shooting this scene. Angela, I loved that the reason your character says she won't get up is because you couldn't get up or we would see your belly. But it's one of those moments where real life, they had to fix that. Why wouldn't Angela get up? So they write this great joke that she refuses to stand, which is just so funny, which I'm not sure they would have thought of if not for the problem of you not being able to stand. Yeah. I love that. I loved when he was like, will you marry me? And my character's like, okay. And then he's like, into the microphone, babe. I'm like, I said, okay. Can you imagine if
他的女士。是的，你可以在这个镜头里看到我的肚子。哦，肯定的。在这个整场戏里，我就是怀孕了，而没有人关心。我喜欢拍摄这场戏。安吉拉，我喜欢你角色说她不上台的原因，是因为你根本站不起来，否则我们就会看到你的肚子。但这就是现实生活中他们不得不解决的那种时刻。为什么安吉拉不肯站起来？所以他们写了一个绝妙的笑话，她拒绝站起来，这实在是太搞笑了，如果不考虑你无法站立的问题，我真不确定他们能不能想出这一招。是的。我太喜欢了。我喜欢当他说，你愿意嫁给我吗？然后我的角色说，好吧。然后他说，对着麦克风说，宝贝。我说，我说了，好吧。你能想象如果
you asked someone to marry them and their answer was, I said, okay. With a bite to it, I said, okay. And the crowd goes wild. I know. Kelly runs up and says, can I be a bridesmaid? Oh, yeah. And Angela's like, no. In the script, there was an Angela talking head after the proposal. First of all, in the script, she starts off the talking head by showing off the engagement ring. It is written that it is a giant yellow diamond with a huge inclusion. If you were wondering. Okay. And then here's Angela's talking head. I don't like options in life. Options make me jittery and crazy. Like I just had a cup of green tea. I like order. I like answers. I like knowing this is where you'll work. This is what you'll wear.
你向某人求婚，他们的回答是，我说了，好吧。带着一点情绪，我说，我说了，好吧。人群疯狂了。我知道。凯利跑过来问，我能当伴娘吗？哦，是的。然后安吉拉说，不行。在剧本中，求婚后有一个安吉拉的访谈镜头。首先，在剧本中，她通过展示订婚戒指开始了访谈镜头。剧本里写着这是一颗巨大的黄钻，里面有一个巨大的内含物。如果你想知道的话。好吧。然后是安吉拉的访谈镜头：我不喜欢生活中的选项。选项让我神经质和疯狂。就像我刚刚喝了一杯绿茶。我喜欢秩序。我喜欢答案。我喜欢知道这就是你工作的地方。这就是你穿的衣服。
This is what you'll come home to. Great. Done. Let's get married. I love you too. Says it all. That's all you need to know. She's ordering her life. And I think Dwight is too unpredictable. You just don't know with him and she can't control him. And you know, she came home to a dead frozen cat and she'll have none of those shenanigans ever again. Well, certainly not with Andy. She is the boss of Andy for sure. This is a very comfortable, predictable relationship. That's right. On her terms. Completely. Well, guys, Jim puts the ring away. Oh, I know. He is not going to propose on the same night in the same place that Andy proposes. And Pam seems to be a little bit upset. I have to say, good call, Jim. Well,
这就是你下班后回到的家。太棒了。搞定。我们结婚吧。我也爱你。一切尽在不言中。这就是你需要知道的全部。她在将自己的生活井井有条化。而且我认为德怀特太不可预测了。你跟他在一起根本捉摸不透，而且她无法控制他。你知道的，她回到家看到的是一只死掉的冰冻猫，她再也不想经历那些恶作剧了。好吧，对安迪来说绝对不会。她绝对是安迪的老板。这是一段非常舒适、可预测的关系。没错。完全按她的条件来。完全如此。好吧，伙计们，吉姆把戒指收起来了。哦，我知道。他才不会在安迪求婚的同一个晚上、同一个地点求婚呢。帕姆看起来有点沮丧。我不得不说，干得好，吉姆。好吧，
yeah, I mean, Pam is upset, but she's got to know. Wait, Jim is like a smart guy and there's no way he would propose to me after that crazy overture from Andy in front of everyone. You don't want that as a part of your engagement story when you go out to dinner and know all that jazz. And also, I do want to say, I don't know, did Jim have time to like call her parents and ask for her hand in marriage because this seems a little traditional to me. There is a scene in the script where Jim is trying to call Pam's mom and is leaving her a message. And he's just like, Hey, I've tried you a few times, just need to get ahold of you. So Jim was trying to call your mom. Okay. Yeah, I like that. I don't know who's more bummed, Pam or Dwight. I think Dwight. Yeah, he's really,
是的，我是说，帕姆很沮丧，但她心里有数。等等，吉姆是个聪明人，在安迪在所有人面前发表了那番疯狂的表白之后，他绝不可能向我求婚。你可不想让那种事成为你出去吃晚饭时聊的求婚故事的一部分。而且我也想说，我不知道，吉姆有时间给她的父母打电话征求他们同意把女儿嫁给他吗，因为这对我来说似乎有点传统。剧本里确实有一个场景，吉姆试图给帕姆的妈妈打电话并给她留言。他只是说，嘿，我试着联系你几次了，只是需要找你一下。所以吉姆确实尝试给你妈妈打电话了。好的。是的，我喜欢这样。我不知道谁更郁闷，是帕姆还是德怀特。我想是德怀特。是的，他真的、
really sad. He actually says, well, it's my own fault. Yeah, but Pam is pretty bummed. And it's right at this moment that Toby is going to try to take a picture with her. Yeah, he's got this fancy camera, which I do remember there's a whole deleted scene where he has purchased this fancy camera. Yeah, suddenly. It's really funny, you guys. I filmed it and I texted it to Paul because it made me laugh so hard. He comes in with this camera. And he asked Jim, he's like, Hey, picture and Jim and Pam are at reception talking and Jim and Pam are like, sure. And they start posing for Toby to take pictures of them. And they're like, smiley, silly one, crazy one. And like, Toby is like, Oh, God, and he just walks away. It's so funny. But he's clearly gone out and
真的很伤心。他实际上说，好吧，这是我自找的。是的，但帕姆也很沮丧。就在这个时候，托比试图和她合影。是的，他拿着这个昂贵的相机，我确实记得有一个完整的被删减场景，讲他买了这个昂贵的相机。是的，突然之间。这真的很好笑，伙计们。我拍下来并发短信给保罗了，因为它把我笑惨了。他拿着这个相机进来了。他问吉姆，他就像是，嘿，拍张照吧，吉姆和帕姆在接待处聊天，吉姆和帕姆就说，当然。他们开始摆好姿势让托比给他们拍照。他们就像是，笑一个，傻气的，疯狂的。然后托比就像是，哦，天哪，然后他就走开了。太搞笑了。但他显然是出门去买的，
he's pretending like he bought it for Costa Rica. But the truth is, he's bought this very fancy camera so he could get a picture with Pam. It's finally going to happen. Yeah. Meredith takes a picture. She says, Pam, your smile is weird. She's distracted by her non proposal that just happened. But Toby is delighted. You see him later, just like sitting and scrolling through these pictures of him and Pam. Right about this time, Michael gets back to the party and Holly tells him all about what happened. Andy proposed to an accountant. And Michael says, well, it could have been Oscar or Angela. Really? Yes. He could see either one happening. And that's when Holly opens the door. She says, gosh, even after all these ribs and this whole party, I'm still a little hungry.
并且假装他是为去哥斯达黎加买的。但事实是，他买这个非常昂贵的相机是为了能和帕姆合张影。这终于要发生了。是的。梅雷迪思拍了一张照片。她说，帕姆，你的笑容好怪。她被刚刚发生的非求婚事件分心了。但托比很高兴。你看到他后来，就像坐在那里翻看这些他和帕姆的照片。就在这个时候，迈克尔回到了派对上，霍莉把发生的一切都告诉了他。安迪向一个会计求婚了。迈克尔说，好吧，本来也可能是奥斯卡或安吉拉。真的吗？是的。他觉得这两种情况都有可能发生。就在这时，霍莉打开了门。她说，天哪，即使吃了这么多排骨和这个派对的食物，我还是有点饿。
I thought maybe I'd go get some dessert. Michael says, Oh, you should go to the glider diner. Ask Stanley about it. He goes there all the time. And she's like, Oh, oh, okay. Well, Michael is distracted. Yeah. He has just had such a huge life curveball thrown at him. He's just not there in the moment with her. Well, Kevin's there in the moment. He overhears. He says, let's go. She's like, great. That's terrific. So now she's going to go off and have dessert with Kevin. Angela, I looked up the glider diner. It's a real place. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. It's in downtown Scranton. It's right across from the Scranton Memorial Stadium. It was opened in 1945 by Chappy Lestrange and the late Jean Cosgrove Senior. Chappy Lestrange? Chappy Lestrange.
我想也许我应该去吃点甜点。迈克尔说，哦，你应该去滑翔机餐厅（Glider Diner）。问问斯坦利。他经常去那儿。然后她说，哦，哦，好吧。迈克尔分心了。是的。他刚刚经历了一个人生中巨大的曲线球。他现在没有心思和她在一起。好吧，凯文在那儿。他无意中听到了。他说，我们走吧。她说，太好了。那太棒了。所以现在她要和凯文一起去吃甜点了。安吉拉，我查了滑翔机餐厅。那是个真实的地方。哦，是的。哦，是的。它在斯克兰顿市中心。它就在斯克兰顿纪念体育场对面。它于1945年由查皮·勒斯特朗日（Chappy Lestrange）和已故的吉恩·科斯格罗夫高级（Jean Cosgrove Senior）开业。查皮·勒斯特朗日？查皮·勒斯特朗日。
That is a name and then some. I love it. What about his partner, Jean Cosgrove Senior? I mean, come on, these two. These are great names. Chappy and Jean. They were both in the service together. And when they got out, they decided they wanted to go in the restaurant business. It was tough times at first. Chappy had to sell tires on the side to keep things going. But it succeeded and the restaurant is still run by Chappy and his son, Charlie. Chappy and Charlie. This was any inspiration for what's coming ahead in work bus where Laverne's pies and tires. I wonder. This is a diner and he had to sell tires on the side. It's very possible. The glider diner is open seven days a week and they're open until 10 p.m. Monday through Saturday. So don't worry. Holly and Kevin
这名字可真够长的。我太喜欢了。他的合伙人吉恩·科斯格罗夫高级呢？我是说，拜托，这两个人。这些都是好名字。查皮和吉恩。他们以前一起服过兵役。当他们退伍时，他们决定从事餐饮业。一开始日子很艰难。查皮不得不兼职卖轮胎来维持生计。但他们成功了，这家餐厅现在仍由查皮和他的儿子查理经营。查皮和查理。这会不会是后来《工作巴士》（Work Bus）里“拉维恩馅饼和轮胎店”（Laverne's Pies and Tires）的灵感来源？我很好奇。这是一家餐厅，而他不得不兼职卖轮胎。这完全有可能。滑翔机餐厅一周七天营业，周一到周六营业到晚上10点。所以别担心。霍莉和凯文
have plenty of time to get dessert and here are their choices. I looked up the desserts. They can have rice pudding, baked pie, cake slice, baked pie with ice cream, tapioca pudding, ice cream sundae, ice cream or special dessert. Lady, can we add this to the tour list and can I just propose that we get special dessert? Whatever it is, we're ordering special dessert at the glider diner. We're going to go spend like two weeks in Pennsylvania. We're going to go hit all the spots. We really are. I want to have some of Aunt Mary's meatballs over at Garities and then we're going to finish it off with some special dessert at glider diner. Even though Michael is distracted by Jan and the new baby bump, he's going to remember it's time for Toby to go
有充足的时间去吃甜点，以下是他们的选择。我查了甜点。他们可以吃大米布丁、烤派、切块蛋糕、带冰淇淋的烤派、木薯布丁、冰淇淋圣代、冰淇淋或特色甜点。女士，我们能把它加到巡回清单里吗？我能提议我们点特色甜点吗？不管那是什么，我们在滑翔机餐厅都要点特色甜点。我们要去宾夕法尼亚州呆上大约两个星期。我们要去打卡所有这些地方。我们真的会的。我想在加里蒂吃点玛丽阿姨的肉丸，然后我们要在滑翔机餐厅以特色甜点收尾。尽管迈克尔被珍和新的孕肚分心了，但他还是记得是时候让托比走了，
and he's going to grab Hank the security guard and they're going to escort him out of the damn building. Lady, is there anyone better than Hank? No, Hank's the best. He has like one line and it's just everything about the way he's standing, his body language. Yeah. All of it. Perfect. Hugh Dane was just fantastic. He was just perfect. And as they're walking out, Toby's watch has an alarm that goes off. Well, remember, Michael said it in the morning to the moment that Toby would leave. And now he's finally gone and there is this great Michael talking head. We clearly shot it upstairs in the writer's offices because the Ferris wheel is rotating. You can see the lights out the window. It's really pretty. It's really a nice shot. And
他要抓住保安汉克，他们要把他护送出该死的建筑。女士，还有比汉克更好的人吗？没有，汉克最棒了。他只有一句台词，但他站立的方式、肢体语言，一切都完美。全部。太完美了。休·丹（Hugh Dane）简直棒极了。他简直完美。正当他们走出去时，托比的手表闹钟响了。好吧，记住，迈克尔早上曾精确到托比离开的那一刻。现在他终于走了，有一个非常棒的迈克尔访谈镜头。我们显然是在楼上的编剧办公室拍的，因为摩天轮正在旋转。你可以透过窗户看到外面的灯光。真的很漂亮。真的是个很棒的镜头。他
he's decided to go to Jan's Lamaze class and he says, you know, if there are any details you need to fill me in on, like what exactly Lamaze is, that would be great. Well, as if this episode didn't have enough. We've got this tag. Oh boy. Oh boy. Phyllis is in the elevator. She's talking to camera. She is so excited about how her party went. She says party planning is like a runner's high. It's just her adrenaline, right? But then she overhears a noise, Angela, in the office. And she walks in the front door and tell us what does she see? Oh my gosh. She sees Dwight in Angela like in the throes of passion. You guys don't have clothes on. What is going on? Well, lady, just talk to Paul Feig about how difficult filming this scene was. In the script,
决定去上珍的拉玛泽课程，他说，你知道，如果有任何细节你需要补充告诉我，比如拉玛泽到底是什么，那就太好了。好吧，就好像这一集的内容还不够多一样。我们还有这个彩蛋。天哪。天哪。菲利斯在电梯里。她正在对着镜头说话。她对她的派对办得多么成功感到非常兴奋。她说派对策划就像是跑步者的亢奋（Runner's High）。这只是她的肾上腺素，对吧？但随后她在办公室里听到了一种声音，安吉拉。她从前门走进去，告诉我们她看到了什么？哦天哪。她看到德怀特和安吉拉在激情热吻。你们俩没穿衣服吗？这到底是怎么回事？好吧，女士，只要跟保罗·费格（Paul Feig）谈谈拍摄这场戏有多难就行了。在剧本中，
it says Phyllis walks in and sees Dwight and Angela having sex. Okay. How do you do that? A, network television. B, when the female actress is incredibly pregnant, right? So poor Paul. I feel like Paul Feig always had to deal with awkward stuff with Dwight and Angela and figure out how best to show it, right? We had a whole rehearsal with camera, with no one else in the bullpen, where we tried to simulate a sexy looking shot. And it was impossible. You could not hide my belly. So what they decided to do is A, rain has his shirt off. If you'll notice, all they did was take my hair down from the ponytail. And I have a few buttons undone, but I'm fully in my maternity romper. But here's the thing,
上面写着菲利斯走进去，看到德怀特和安吉拉在做爱。好吧。你怎么拍那样的戏？第一，电视网播出限制。第二，当女演员怀着身孕时，对吧？所以可怜的保罗。我觉得保罗·费格总是得处理德怀特和安吉拉之间那些尴尬的事情，并想出最好的展示方式，对吧？我们和摄像机一起进行了整个排练，办公室里没有其他人，我们试图模拟一个看起来性感的镜头。这根本不可能。你无法藏住我的肚子。所以他们决定做的是：第一，雷恩光着膀子。如果你注意到的话，他们所做的只是把我的头发从马尾辫放下来。我解开了几个扣子，但我完全穿着我的孕妇连裤衫。但问题是，
Angela, your character was always so buttoned up that just to have like your decolletage showing is so shocking. Well, and to have my hair down and all a skew like that, for sure. So they decided rain shirt off was all they needed, me looking disheveled. They did a very far away shot and they framed it over the file cabinet. But all they really needed was for Phyllis to see me and me to see Phyllis. And that was that. Well, rain talked about rehearsing this scene, Angela. He said, yes, you tried a lot of different locations during your rehearsal. He said you guys tried having sex on the copy machine, on Creed's desk, on Michael's desk, on the mail cart, and on the floor by the file cabinets. Yes. That's a lot of places. We did. And here's the thing,
安吉拉，你的角色一向那么保守，仅仅是露出你的锁骨和胸口就已经够令人震惊了。嗯，而且把头发放下来，那样乱蓬蓬的，确实。所以他们决定雷恩光着膀子就是他们所需要的，再加上我看起来衣衫不整的样子。他们拍了一个非常远景的镜头，并把它框在文件柜上方。但他们真正需要的只是菲利斯看到我，而我看到菲利斯。这就行了。好吧，雷恩谈到了排练这场戏，安吉拉。他说，是的，你们在排练期间尝试了很多不同的地点。他说你们尝试在复印机上、在克雷格的桌子上、在迈克尔的桌子上、在送货车上以及文件柜旁的地板上做爱。是的。那是很多地方。我们确实试过。而且事情是这样的，
you have Paul Feig, you have the camera crew, and we're just literally going around the office. Where could these two people be getting it on where you can't tell I'm pregnant? And I think what really sealed the deal on we have to have it more hidden behind the file cabinet is when we tried the floor. Paul Feig literally started laughing and said, okay, stop, stop. Well, rain also said that there was a very big discussion over whether or not he should be wearing his glasses. Yes. Right? Because they'd taken your hair down, like you said. Uh-huh. Then they were like, would Dwight have taken off his glasses? They decided that they had to leave the glasses on so that there would be absolutely no doubt
你有保罗·费格，你有摄像机组，我们实际上只是在办公室里四处转悠。这两个人能在哪里鬼混而又看不出我怀孕了呢？我想真正敲定必须把他们更多地隐藏在文件柜后面的，是我们尝试在地板上的时候。保罗·费格 literalmente（字面意：简直）笑了起来，说，好了，停，停。好吧，雷恩还说，关于他是否应该戴眼镜，曾有过一场非常激烈的讨论。是的。对吧？因为他们把你的头发放下来了，正如你所说。嗯-huh。然后他们就在想，德怀特会摘下眼镜吗？他们决定必须保留眼镜，这样才毫无疑问
who you were having sex with. In rain's words, who was straddling America's favorite accountant? That's what he said. Well, I took a screen grab of the moment they are busted, and I think it's amazing. It's so good. It looks like a cover of a romance novel. I know, like a cheesy, cheesy romance novel. I'm going to put it in our stories. It's really good. Oh, well, someone take that screen grab, please, after Angela posts it and turn that into the cover of a romance novel for me, please, please. I'm begging you. That's pretty great. Well, you know, Jenna, this script would have ended with a Phyllis talking head. What? Yes. In the script, the final moment of this episode is Phyllis, and she is described like this. Phyllis talking head.
和你做爱的人是谁。用雷恩的话说，到底是谁跨坐在全美最受欢迎的会计身上？他是这么说的。好吧，我截了他们被抓包那一刻的屏幕截图，我觉得这太棒了。太棒了。它看起来像一本言情小说的封面。我知道，就像一本俗气、老套的言情小说。我要把它发到我们的快拍里。真的很棒。哦，好吧，等安吉拉发了之后，请谁把那个截图截下来，把它变成我的一本言情小说封面，求求你们了，求求你们了。我求你们了。那真是太棒了。好吧，你知道的，珍娜，这个剧本本该以菲利斯的访谈镜头结束。什么？是的。在剧本中，这一集的最后时刻是菲利斯，她是这样被描述的。菲利斯访谈镜头。
Phyllis is sitting back, relaxed and confident. You're looking at the new head of the party planning committee. I think I'll make Angela my assistant so I don't have to do all the boring stuff. If she doesn't like it, I'm going to sing. I love it. I wish that stayed in. I know, I know, and you guys, that was goodbye, Toby. Part two. And that wraps up season four of The Office. I can't believe it. What's next? Weight loss. Season five weight loss. Holy moly. All right. Well, we would like to thank Jen Salada, Paul Weberstein, Kate Flannery, Rainn Wilson, and of course, Kent Sabornak for answering our questions for this episode. We love you guys. We'll see you in season five. See you then.
菲利斯往后靠着，放松而自信。你现在看到的是派对策划委员会的新负责人。我想让安吉拉当我的助手，这样我就不用做所有无聊的事情了。如果她不喜欢，我就要唱歌。我太喜欢了。我真希望那场戏保留下来。我知道，我知道，伙计们，那就是《再见托比》第二部分。这也为《办公室》第四季画上了句号。我简直不敢相信。接下来是什么？减肥。第五季《减肥》。天哪。好吧。好吧，我们要感谢珍·萨拉塔、保罗·韦伯斯坦（注：应为利伯施泰因）、凯特·弗兰纳里、雷恩·威尔逊，当然还有肯特·萨博纳克回答了我们这一集的问题。我们爱你们，伙计们。我们第五季见。到时候见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是英斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克雷格·布拉特恩的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。